[Musique]
je m'appelle star avec deux mères c'est
papa qui a choisi mon prénom gardonneix
papa et maman disent que notre vie est
ici parce que les nôtres sont ici
le lycée c'est le meilleur endroit pour
se moquer tomber enceinte se faire
braquer on va pas là williamson est un
autre monde
alors quand je suis ici je suis star 2.0
jusqu'à ce que le week-end arrive à
gâteau c'est que maintenant tu traînes
avec des blancs alors bouclée
[Musique]
descendez de la voiture est-ce que ça va
remuer les mains sur la voiture fais ce
qu'il te demande top
revenons maintenant sur la sphère du
meurtre d'un adolescent noir de 17 ans
par un officier de police blanc samedi
soir violence brutalité
on vit dans un monde compliqué je le
trouve pas si pour piquer moi il fallait
pas que des jeunes qui parlent et nous
les noirs comme aux pauvres opprimés
tous les laissés pour compte
il faut que je parle pour lui
coup d'envoi le monde
quand tu sera prête on t'écoutera je
laisserai personne empêcher de parler
haut et fort je ne t'ai pas plus tard
par hasard